Alright guys, so in this video I will teach you the ICT Silver Bullet Trading Strategy. On my YouTube I have already uploaded a video on this topic but it is not like in detail. But in this video I'm going to explain each and everything in detail and how you can trade it to make profits. If that makes sense. Okay, so what ICT exactly says. Listen to this very carefully. He says that before 10 AM, New York time,
Look for a liquidity that has been swept.
So before 10 am, look for liquidity that has been already swept.
Before 10 am, look for liquidity that has been already swept.
Now once you identify the liquidity that has been swept,
you want to identify
liquidity
that has not been swept yet
so let's say that
okay one minute
you have
buy site here
and you have
sell site here right
so this is
buy site
liquidity
and this is sell site
so let's say
before 10 am
you see that price has taken out
out these equal highs over here. So now price could be going up, you know, could be
consolidating whatnot. But after 10M, right, after 10M, look for market structure shift
with displacement on one minute timeframe. Okay. So let's say the clock hits, let me go here.
The clock hits 10 am right here. So 10 am. Yeah. Now you want to start looking for market
structure shifts. Okay, so let's say you get a beautiful displacement, okay, like that. Now,
ICT says you mark out the fair value gap, you take your entry, you put your stop to five handles.
Okay, five handles on E-M-E-S-N-P is going to be somewhere around it. I'm going to teach you what
it means, okay? But for now, he says your stop loss goes to five handles and you take profit goes to
five handles. So basically it tells us to import one to one. Now that in my eyes is very low.
Okay, but it has, he says that it has a probability of around above 80 percent. Okay, so you're
gonna win most of the time. However, what I've noticed with my back testing is, is when you can
simply go for one to two. That is the perfect rich tree wall ratio for the strategy that I found
backtesting. Okay, and when price goes to like one to one, you go break even. So when price comes back to
one to one, you go break even. So here are some key things that you must note. So let's say there's like
a significant low here or maybe here, you know, a significant one. Okay, and price takes out that
low before coming back to your entry. Then you have to be cautious. Okay, because price has already
taken out and sell side it could just go back up again. You want to identify so let me give you
this little example here. So this is external market structure and inside this you're going to have
like this lower low or high lower low or high lower low or high low or high low. So you want to
look for market structure shift of internal market structure. You do not want to look for this
If the price comes back and takes out this low here and then comes back to your entry,
do not take that. It's not going to work out.
You must identify the internal market structure, which is this right here on the one minute
time from. You look for a market structure shift. It happens right here with displacement. Take your
entry. Go for five handles and or just put your stop at the high over here and go for one to two.
So let me let me show you what I mean by handles right.
Let me go to futures right here.
Okay so let's say that your for example okay let's say your entry is at the close
of this body.
You put your entry here.
Now notice this number right here.
Stops 3.50 right.
It shows 3.50.
you move it to 5 and that is your 5 handles stop loss you go for 1 to 1 that is your 5 handles take profit
So let me give you guys a couple of examples and then we will move on to the next topic